Frank Rosin und ich haben eine kleine
Geschichte ich war einmal in seinem
Sternerestaurant welches mit zwei Michel
ausstern bewertet ist habe es getestet
und war ein bisschen enttäuscht also
irgendwie war es das an dem Tag an dem
Abend nicht für mich er hat das dann
auch mitbekommen weil das Video ein
bisschen durch die Decke gegangen ist
und umso unangenehmer war es als ich ihn
getroffen habe bei einem Sterne food
Festival wo nur Sterneköche waren ich
habe mit ihm gesprochen ich habe alles
wieder aus der Welt geschaffen ja heute
sitze ich wieder da möchte etwas von dem
Testen und zwar seine Rezepte in Rosins
Restaurants rettet er Restaurants welche
aus planerischen finanziellen oder auch
einfach kochtechnischen Gründen vor dem
Ruin stehen deshalb gibt er den
Restaurants häufiger mal einfacher
Rezepte an die Hand mit denen sie ihren
Laden auf Vordermann bringen können drei
verschiedene Sachen stehen heute auf dem
Plan eine sie gut ist besser als die
andere würde sagen lass uns das ganze
probieren und wir beginnen mit Chili con
Carne los geht's mit unserem Chili con
Carne so wie es hier steht wo das in
Rosins Restaurants gekocht wir haben
Hackfleisch und Tomaten die haben
eigentlich alles was so ein klassisches
Chil benötigt aber es gibt den ein oder
anderen Kniff denn nur Frank Rosin kennt
deshalb müssen wir testen wie gut das
Ganze am Ende schmeckt und wir fangen an
indem wir erstmal unsere beiden Töpfe
warm machen Eintopf für das Fleisch
Eintopf um ein bisschen Gemüse
anzuschwitzen wir geben in beide Töpfe
ein wenig Olivenöl Zwiebeln schalotten
und Knoblauch so die Zwiebeln schwitzen
vor sich hin glaubst du dass Chili con
Carne kommt an unser Chili con Carne für
Marc Eggers ran es ist ein bisschen
unfair weil das wird ein europäisches
Chili con Carne bei dem Chili con Carne
für Mark Eggers haben wir auch
mexikanische Chilis benutzt und sowas
deshalb könnte ich mir vorstellen dass
es nicht ganz rankommt aber ich glaube
trotzdem dass es im eins zu eins
vergleicht bei vielen Leuten besser
abschneiden würde weil es halt einfach
bekannt ist denn Chili Anteil hier ist
auch wirklich sehr niedrig sehr gering
ich weiß ja nicht genau für welches
Restaurant das war aber für so ein
normales gutbürgerliches Restaurant
sollte man auch nicht zu Crazy gehen
ich sag dir ehrlich ich finde glaube ich
wirklich sogar das Zwiebeln in dem Topf
oder einer Pfanne noch krasser riechen
als so ein krankes Steak anzubraten das
ist wirklich
krassesten geben so viel Duft und
Geschmack ab auch erwähnenswert dass es
gemischtes Hackfleisch also das ist kein
Podcast
das werde ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen
ausbreiten damit es möglichst viel
Kontaktfläche bekommt jetzt geben wir
auch den Knoblauch dazu knoblauch ist
dann empfindlichsten deshalb erst zu
diesem Zeitpunkt ich verstehe den Punkt
auf jeden Fall dass separat zu machen ja
klar weil ich meine hier drin wird es
halt verbrennen jetzt gerade ne ich
glaube das wird gut abgehen einer dieser
Tops und gusseiserner Topf ist wirklich
durch nichts zu ersetzen wunderbar kommt
keine Farbe dran die werden einfach
glasig genau es reicht mir eigentlich
auch schon also gehe ich hier mit der
Hitze runter hier hinten ist mehr mehr
also je länger wir warten desto geiler
wird das hier ich habe erst jetzt wieder
ein bisschen Öl hinzugefügt weil jetzt
haben wir schon ein paar Röststoffe am
Boden aber so wird dann noch mal so die
die Ecken von diesem kleinen Stücken
werden jetzt noch mal richtig schön
knusprig ja wir haben hier richtig was
am Boden also lasst euch nicht wundern
dass das Hackfleisch noch grau ist weil
die ganzen Geschmacksstoffe und die
Röstaromen sitzen hier am Boden die
kommen gleich ab und zwar nehmen wir das
alles hier hinüber gegeben haben
Zwiebeln einmal raus unsere glasierten
Zwiebeln Knoblauch verlockend sind dazu
jetzt kommt auch direkt die Farbe schon
so langsam ab vom Topfboden aber nur
damit wir sie uns an anderer Stelle
wiederholen mit ein bisschen Tomatenmark
damit homematifizieren wir das ganze was
ist denn das jetzt wisst jetzt einen
Kaffee trinken wir sind noch am arbeiten
hier ein Kaffee trinken okay gib mal ein
paar mal herum
[Musik]
machst du denn jetzt
entschuldigen Café reinmachen genauso
wir haben jetzt gerade probiert die
Szene nachzustellen aus Rosins
Restaurants weil da kommt auch so
jemanden rein und gib diesen Kaffee ab
und das ist aber muss ich wirklich sagen
beim so ein kleiner Heck der und Streit
war das der Frank auf jeden Fall einiges
an Wissen hat was das Kochen angeht das
sind so die kleinen Tipps gerade so ein
schöner amerikano so einen guten
Espresso drin hat Power 4 Flüssigkeit
ist das nicht die verkocht nämlich
direkt geht jetzt noch zwei
Lorbeerblätter dazu so die werden dann
auch mit köcheln Lorbeerblätter auch so
ein Mysterium ne bringen die wirklich
was ich glaube keiner weiß trinke ich
nicht für dich hier rein ein wenig
Rotwein 200 Milliliter waren das und es
riecht wirklich schon sehr sehr gut die
Chili ist bei einem authentischen Chili
con Carne haben ja auch so eine
Kaffeenote so das Imitieren wir einfach
jetzt indem wir so einen schwarzen
Kaffee dazwischen das ganze kocht hier
fleißig vor sich hin hier haben wir
jetzt die Chili con Carne Gewürzmischung
von der wir ein bisschen in den Topf
geben ist nicht genau beschrieben da ist
so wenig drin was so typischen Geschmack
gibt es geht da ein bisschen mehr von
rein eine ganz normale chili ist ein
Supermarkt klein geschnitten mit Kern
die rühren wir auch noch mitunter so
nächster ab passierte Tomaten ihr seht
vielleicht wir haben auch normale
Tomaten da stehen und als nächstes
werden wir sie entkernen dafür halbieren
wir unsere Tomaten im vierten wir Sie
und schneiden wir einmal hier oben am
Sprung rein dann können wir einfach das
Innere so rausnehmen und schneiden das
dann noch klein so sehen die Tomaten
entkernt und klein geschnitten aus die
geben wir noch dazu dann kommen jetzt
einfach noch die Kidneybohnen dazu Mais
kommt dazu der Mais gibt ein bisschen
süße aber ein bisschen extra süße holen
wir uns mit einer Prise Zucker noch raus
und alles was ihr sonst noch seht
Zitrone Koriander Frühlingszwiebel ist
zum Garnieren da deswegen so lassen wir
das jetzt kochen und wir sehen uns
gleich zum Probieren wieder so sieht das
ganze gute 2 Stunden später aus deutlich
weniger Flüssigkeit was darauf schließen
lässt dass sich der Geschmack auch
deutlich konzentriert hat aber dafür
muss erstmal Geschmack da sein und das
werden wir jetzt herausfinden ob er da
drin ist nehme mir meinen Löffel sind
schon mal rein aber bei Niere das ganze
noch genauso wie Frank Rosin mit ein
wenig zitronenzeste nicht wundern die
ist grün das sind trotzdem Zitronen
keine Limetten Frühlingszwiebeln den wir
auch dazu den Koriander das hier ist es
also das erste Frank Rosinen Gericht für
heute verköstigen also es sieht aus wie
das was du bekommst wenn du in einem
gutbürgerlichen Restaurant was ja voll
sein Ding ist und Chili con Carne
bestellt
also sind auf jeden Fall ein paar
interessante Noten dabei ich glaube
nicht zuletzt auch vom Kaffee aber hier
muss man natürlich ganz klar sagen die
Zielgruppe geht halt in Restaurant
irgendwo auf dem Land und möchte den
Chili con Carne Essen ich glaube da bist
du da eigentlich auf der richtigen Seite
das muss jetzt wirklich schmecken weil
wir machen eine Currywurst nach Frank
Rosins Rezept alles was wir brauchen
steht hier und ich bin wirklich
überrascht ich habe noch nie in meinem
Leben eine Currywurst gemacht deshalb
möchte ich gar nicht sagen dass das
irgendwie anders oder falsch oder
irgendwas ist aber ich sehe immer auf
tiktok dass die Leute Currywurst Soße
mit Cola und Apfelmus machen und wie ihr
seht es sucht man vergebens wir haben
Currypulver Paprikapulver Tomatenmark
Chili Zwiebel viel Paprika bisschen
Brühe bisschen Weißwein also nachdem was
ich gesehen habe ganz andere Zutaten und
ich finde es interessant dass man das
gleiche Ergebnis erzielen kann diese
Currywurst muss in sich haben diese Soße
muss ja krass sein das ist uns
zubereiten wir machen dafür erstmal
unseren Topf an hier geben ein wenig
Olivenöl in den Topf dann geben wir
unsere Bibel und so sieht das Ganze aus
wenn es ein wenig angeschwitzt ist hat
immer noch so ein bisschen bis aber das
kriegt seine Zeit noch wir nehmen jetzt
eine viert Tomatenmark irgendwie einfach
dazu und tomatifizieren wieder jetzt
gebe ich auch meinen Knoblauch und eine
geschnittene Chili dazu man merkt schon
das klebt jetzt langsam hier so ein
bisschen an das heißt wir können
ablöschen und das machen wir mit einem
halben Liter Rinderbrühe und was
natürlich auch nicht fehlen darf ist ein
kleines Stückchen Weißwein einfach weil
es ein frank rosinenrezept ist okay dann
haben wir noch drei Gewürze bzw ist
Zucker in Gewürz habe ich das erste
schon gespoilert geben wir dazu
Currypulver und Paprikapulver Salz gebe
ich erst dazu wenn das ganze eingekocht
ist damit es ein bisschen besser
abschmecken kann aber doch ich habe das
Gefühl es hat schon so eine leichte
dicke jetzt von Currywurst also der
Geruch auf jeden Fall darauf habe ich
mich schon die ganze Zeit gefreut dass
blubbert vor sich hin hat echt schon so
ein bisschen
Wabbel drin und ich glaube das wird nur
noch mehr wenn wir das ganze jetzt
pürieren wenn man ein bisschen Sorgen um
unsere T-Shirts deshalb fange ich
vorsichtig an
okay ordentlich durchpüriert so dicken
wir das ganze jetzt noch ein bisschen
ein indem wir einfach noch ein bisschen
köcheln lassen ihr seht schon das kocht
noch ein bisschen auf dickt jetzt ein
bisschen ein und dann bin ich mir
relativ sicher haben wir hier ein
präsentables Ergebnis geschaffen und wie
das Ganze schmeckt steht auf einer
anderen Karte so Leute das hier ist eine
schöne gegrillte Currywurst
beziehungsweise gerade ist es noch eine
Bratwurst wir machen sie jetzt aber zu
einer Currywurst einfach so richtig
schön imbissstyle Probestücke ab auf
unseren Teller Soße drüber wenn man
rausgeht auf die Straße und jemand fragt
was ist das dann wird die Person auf
jeden Fall sagen Currywurst so viel sei
gesagt war eine Sache ist noch ganz
wichtig bisschen Currypulver oder ganz
genau hatte im Video nicht gemacht aber
ich finde das muss wirklich nicht
gemacht werden
also allein für die Optiken Salz Pfeffer
habe ich gerade noch mal dazu gegeben
aber den Geschmackstest können wir jetzt
erst zusammen machen finde so die Soße
hat schon eine sehr gute Konsistenz so
Currywurst Soße die ich kenne häufig so
noch homogener also hat so gar keine
Mikro Stückchen drin sondern ist einfach
so quasi eine Flüssigkeit
die Soße ist sehr lecker sehr fruchtig
aus sehr frisch finde die hat so einen
richtigen so ein homemade Charakter also
sie erinnert schon etwas ferner an die
Currywurst Soße die man so kennt so
diese die auch so ein bisschen
industriell ist so aber sie ist ja auch
komplett selbstgemacht komplett frisch
so das ist nicht die Standard Currywurst
Soße wir müssen ja ein bisschen anders
bewerten das Restaurant wo er dieses
Rezept gezeigt hat
Qualität zu zeigen bis jetzt auch nicht
hochpreisig oder so in der Folge gesehen
so eine Currywurst das heißt sie ehrlich
würde ich mich freuen weil es mal was
erfrischendes neues ist dazu eine
richtig geile Pommes Mario ich wäre sehr
glücklich es wäre es wäre so oh nice wir
haben eine besondere Currywurst würde
man sagen ja die Wurst macht noch viel
damit so diese Kombination daraus wird
erst besonders beim Abschmecken dachte
ich so oh oh wo geht das jetzt hin geht
auch sogar echt eine angenehme Schärfe
von dieser einen Chilischote und ein
bisschen Pfeffer ich bin happies gemacht
zu haben das auf jeden Fall das auf
jeden Fall ist für mich schwer ist
einzuordnen weil es halt so hier spielen
so gute Currywürste die ich gegessen
habe und das ist doch hier so also nicht
auf der Skala sondern es woanders ist
ein Wind für mich aber einer wo man ein
bisschen drüber nachdenken muss ja man
muss das erst verstehen ab hinter die
Kamera mit dir wir haben gemischtes Hack
Gewürze Soßen Gewürzgurken Salat und
Burgers was könnte es wohl sein sind der
Burger Bands dass er machen wir jetzt
auch Burger aber anders als jeder
einzelne Burger den ich jemals gemacht
habe und das liegt allein daran
gemischtes Hack also das Rezept möchte
ich auch dazu sagen fairerweise ist ein
bisschen älter das ist irgendwie 6 7 8
Jahre alt aber ein Burger also mit
Schweinehack das ist schon ein bisschen
komisch zwei zu eins Anteil Rind Schwein
wir gehen dazu Paprikapulver und Curry
dann ein bisschen Salz wir geben noch
ein bisschen Pfeffer dran also ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich habe noch niemals
niemals im Leben ein Burger Patty so
gewirkt aber ich meine ich bin auch
nicht Frank Rosin so der der weiß ja was
er macht deshalb bin ich umso gespannt
ob wir jetzt hier die absolute
Überraschung erwarten Bro mit der
Currywurst waren wir genauso entzückt am
Ende also vielleicht ist es auch eine
Offenbarung die auf uns zukommt jetzt
ist alles langsam gebunden kneten wir
das mal ein bisschen weiter durch ist
schon echt außergewöhnlich also gerade
dadurch dass das Schwein und Rind ist
will ich es eigentlich ganz gerne gut
durchkneten dann halbieren wir das ganze
einfach weil wir machen heute zwei
Burger ein Patty hat dann genau 150
Gramm wir teilen das jetzt einfach nach
Auge in der Mitte das aber auch lange
nicht das einzige was außergewöhnlich
ist heute zack
zwei schöne Patties da fehlen uns noch
eine schöne Sache und zwar eine schöne
burgersoße die macht ja als nächstes wir
nehmen ein wenig Senf ordentlich Mayo
sind Tomatenmark und Weißweinessig geben
das alles zusammen und vermengen ist und
das auf den ersten Blick ein bisschen
anders aber basic clean ist das die in
ein outsoße Essig Weißweinessig ist ja
eigentlich genau das in dem halt die
Gurken eingelegt sind die bei der
innenoutsoße reinkommt und die anderen
Zutaten sind gleich außerhalb des Zug
statt Ketchup hier Tomatenmark hast also
die Burger Soße ist eigentlich sehr sehr
vielversprechend haben wir unsere
Gewürzgurken und alles was wir sonst
noch brauchen dann würde ich sagen wir
gehen unsere Bands geschlossen in den
Ofen Zack und Braten unsere Patties so
dann haben wir hier noch Bergkäse kein
American cheese kein Cheddar sondern
Bergkäse finde ich hat aber auch nur
Daseinsberechtigung safe aber ich gehe
so kommt ja mit einer Kräftigkeit noch
mal daher kenne ich aber auch nicht von
Burgern einmal zurechtgeschnitten und
jetzt legen wir unsere Patties einmal
auf Raten die schön durch okay wir
schauen einmal unter unser Patty wow
also sehr interessant die ganzen Säfte
bleiben scheinbar im Patty weil sie
treten ja nicht aus jetzt legen wir
unseren Bergkäse drauf lass mal einen
Petting und Glocke den Käse schmelzen
okay
so leicht crunchy auf der Außenseite
innen drin schön fluffig eigentlich
genau gegenseitiger Ansatz von dem was
man kennt also dass man die Innenseite
tauschen und Außenstoff weg lässt aber
wir wollen mal belegen oben und unten
ordentlich von unserer selbstgemachten
burgersoße so und das ganze wurde jetzt
auch so extra betont verstreichen wir
schön bis zu den Rändern will jetzt mal
gerne im Vergleich der Käse sehen
das macht schon
unterschiedlich Salat auf die Unterseite
und auf die Oberseite dann nehmen wir
die Tomate die Tomate wird nicht extra
gesalzen Zwiebelringe das hat jetzt aber
wiederum schon so was richtig gut
bürgerliches finde ich so diese rohen
Zwiebelringe auf dem Burger das ist
schon auch geil Gewürzgurke jetzt wird
Zeit für die Patties oben drauf das
sieht richtig aus dicker jetzt so im
Gesamtbild wieder ja Deckel drauf sieht
richtig gut aus aber ob er auch
schmecken wird sehen wir jetzt und dafür
haben wir einen Experten für Burger da
dann wollen wir doch mal schauen ob
dieses Restaurant hier gerettet werden
kann dave ist unser Special Guest und
wir schneiden an Gott gucken wir uns mal
ein Querschnitt an es sieht ja sag du
mal wie es aussieht das Fleisch schon
irgendwas drin ich war ja beim Kochen
nicht dabei irgendeine Patina die ich
noch nicht richtig zuordnen kann es
sieht nach so einem Burger aus den du
privat nicht machen würdest weißt du es
nicht so Smash ist nicht so besonders
sieht so das ist schon mal auf jeden
Fall richtig das habe ich auch schon
gesagt
geil aber keine wirkliche Besonderheit
ich bin super weil es klebt nicht so
verklebt den Mund nicht so also es ist
es tut alles was es soll das hält auch
ordentlich zusammen also der Burger
zerfällt jetzt nicht mehr krass super
sehr solide von zehn das Fleisch ist
anders ich weiß nicht richtig was es ist
sieht anders aus es schmeckt ein
bisschen anders es ist geil aber ich
habe keine Ahnung was was da drin ist
das Fleisch schmeckt wirklich
interessant ganz ganz anders als man es
kennt aber alles in allem die Soße ist
auch top super Soße ist super Ernst
kritisch und ich wollte wirklich nicht
kritisch sein beim Rezept habe ich dann
immer gedacht oh je was wird das nicht
dass ich darüber urteilen dürfte sondern
einfach weil es so anders ist als alles
was ich bisher gemacht habe aber
eigentlich bei Außenanschluss allen
Sachen haben die Sachen die Kurve
bekommen und waren sehr lecker deshalb
Props für die Rezepte und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Video wieder ach so da ist
das letzte Video
für diesen Zuschauer persönlich
vorgeschlagen ach so krass ich will
jetzt sofort mein vorgeschlagenes Video
gucken macht ihr es auch dann sehen wir
uns beim diesem Video wieder ciao und
bis dahin